there's lots of places in shiyanagi we
can block or stop people doing she and
Aggie but I'm not trying to block him
I'm just trying to watch
everything's good here hands in front of
head as he turns
good okay so that means you kept your
hat my hands in front of your head last
time he didn't and and so the moment he
goes like that
he's got me
and that's what this Joe work is showing
you all right it's showing you that that
when you don't have a lot of space
you get your hips through
and you keep your head out
and you you tell people off after fourth
queue for stepping but they always they
always do aren't you and Aggie they
shouldn't be doing that with the gel
you're actually stepping because you're
doing it with a Joe
[Music]
good
foreign
Aggie
um
[Music]
I I wasn't taught stuff by Saito Sensei
that I've worked out for myself and that
is
I put in my book nobody seems totally
notice of it but I put it in there that
I can see my hands I can still see my
hands I can still see my hands
and if you just stick by that plan
you'll be able to do much stronger she
and Aggies
if you forget that plan and you just go
oh yeah I just go here and I turn and I
turn quick you see where my hand's now
behind my head and if he's a strong guy
or he's from another organization he
thinks I just show my kiddos better than
his
you know he pulls you over you fell a
real idiot and you go what level are you
and you and he goes second down and
you're fourth and you go oh let's just
go on with it because you don't want to
tell him yours do you
he's pulled you over he's made you look
an idiot
so so I've said to beginners always look
[Music]
at your hands
and then you hike it I'll be sound